okay welcome this is going to be a
presentation focused on cancer
prevention for the practicing oncologist
and what I'm going to do I serve as the
vice president head of the division of
cancer prevention and population
sciences at the MD Anderson Cancer
Center in Houston Texas and I'm going to
share with you a little bit about how we
provide prevention services at a large
Cancer Center so first of all
disclosures I have consulted with a
couple of companies working in
prevention they're described here but
none of the content that I'm going to
share with you today has any anything
any interactions whatsoever with those
with those past commitments to begin
there's a lot that we can do to prevent
cancer in 2019 it's estimated now that
1/3 to 1/2 of all cancer deaths are
preventable in the United States and
other Western populations so that's a
very important message but to realize
the potential of prevention it needs to
be effected in two domains
first of all in personal actions that
are taken every day by every individual
and we'll summarize those here on this
slide they're captured in the yellow box
complementing those active activities on
a personal basis most often communicated
in a clinical context will be
population-based actions and the actions
are largely the same the challenge is
delivering them both to individuals in a
clinical context as well as to the
population as a whole so that the
healthy choice is the easy choice and
the one that serves as a default so
first of all a quick summary of the
personal actions that are important to
reduce cancer risks maintain a healthy
weight across the lifespan second
avoiding known carcinogens the most
prominent of being tobacco and alcohol
third eating a healthy diet and being
physically active fifth knowing your
family history and communicating that to
family members
next avoiding excessive natural or
artificial UV radiation or sunlight
really important because skin cancer
remains the most common cancer in most
populations and certainly here in the
u.s. seventh following a cancer
screening program so now we have many
evidence-based actions and we know
results in reductions in cancer
mortality so availing yourselves of
those tests when they're appropriate is
one major way that we can reduce cancer
risk and then finally there are now some
14 or so fda-approved agents to either
reduce the risk of cancer or to our to
prevent cancer and so availing
yourselves of those again in a clinical
context are very important so now we'll
go into how those services are delivered
at a major Cancer Center like MD
Anderson here in Houston and we offer a
cancer preventive services in our Lyta
Hill cancer prevention center it serves
now roughly about 50,000 patient visits
per year and we deliver our care in five
domains
first of all risk assessment that
includes things like both qualitative as
well as quantitative assessments of an
individual's risk for one or more
cancers and the examples here for breast
cancer for women using something like
the Gail model as well as offering
genetic testing when that's appropriate
based upon one's history next domain
prevention and there we're talking about
advancing healthy lifestyles in a
proactive manner as well as providing
access to medical and surgical
interventions that can reduce cancer
risk next of course offering cancer
screening services and again as I
mentioned we have four or five now that
are evidence-based and known to result
in reductions in cancer mortality for
the general population and then for
high-risk individuals in many instances
we'll offer additional screening next on
the list
tying screening into action or that is
moving from a screen positive state out
to a dying
dosis with subsequent interventions very
important so we offer specialized entry
into diagnostic services as well and
then finally our Center is progressively
becoming not only a cancer prevention
center but a survivorship center as well
as we take patients that have completed
their therapy successfully in one of our
treatment centers and our prevention
center offers a bridge back to primary
care many times offering specialized
services in survivorship then again I'll
cover briefly toward the end of the
presentation but beginning at the
beginning let's talk a bit about
familial and genetic risk so first of
all why is that important well it's
important because it guides many of it
not only informs but guides some of the
subsequent actions so knowing one's
hereditary predisposition of cancer can
help a patient understand why they
develop cancer in the first place
it can provide information about
subsequent risks for second cancers many
times an individual with a cancer will
be at elevated risk compared to the
general population for a second cancer
in that site or elsewhere third that
knowledge or information shared between
a clinician as well as a patient can
inform subsequent decision-making for
things like screening options many times
depending on the age of the cancer the
frequency when the cancer occurred can
determine the subsequent actions in
terms of the type of screening the
frequency or intensity next it also will
many times inform blood relatives of
their cancer risk and therefore put them
on a different screening schedule or
clinical risk assessment process next up
many times these days knowledge of
genetic risks can also guide treatment
options for a diagnosed cancer and then
finally of course many times these days
that knowledge is informing clinical
trial opportunities as well so what
colleges are recommended to do is first
of all take a complete family history as
well as personal history for the patient
in front of them and document that in
the medical record it's important for
practicing physicians to be current on
recommendations and guidelines for both
referral as well as genetic testing as
well and those are available from any
number of sources I'll I highlighted
three of them here the NCCN has genetic
testing guidelines the US Preventive
Services Task Force has them similarly
and many professional organizations such
as ASCO or Surgical groups will will
publish those on a period update them on
a periodic basis the premise for all of
that is a accurate and thorough family
history and what we do here is recommend
gaining gaining knowledge regarding
cancer that have occurred in first
second and third degree relatives
documenting that again in something like
a family history algorithm noting the
age of each of those relatives the time
of a diagnosis of cancer important to
capture issues relevant to ethnicity as
well since some cancers tend to occur
more so in some ethnicities as opposed
to others and then noting the presence
of other chronic diseases and all of
that is captured in at at MD Anderson in
treatment algorithms this is displaying
our genetic counseling algorithm as one
example but you'll see this is just page
two of eight so these are much larger
and more complex than I have time to
review but I'm more or less wanted to
make sure that you are aware that
they're available and you'll see a hot
link there at the bottom of the page if
you're interested in in any of you of
these that I'll share with you they're
publicly available on the web next we'll
move on to a little discussion around
what we do in prevention so one of the
things that we've done over the last
four or five years as the evidence has
accumulated and become more and more
convincing that healthy lifestyles are
important in reducing cancer risk as we
except we specifically try to make sure
every
encounter we have with someone who's
otherwise healthy visiting our cancer
prevention center is comprehensive in
scope so they may come here for breast
screening but we want to try to
intentionally make sure that we're
addressing the full spectrum of
contributors to cancer risk and so this
is something that we've termed the our
integrative health initiative and it
focuses on activities in five domains
across our campus and in the cancer
prevention Center we highlight three of
them in particular because of their
known association in boosting cancer
risk and so we'll now talk about how we
approach nutrition physical activity as
well as tobacco and their association
with cancer risk so first of all as I as
I mentioned we have a dedicated effort
now to try to promote healthy lifestyles
in the cancer prevention center our
mid-level providers as well as our
physicians and nurses all take this very
seriously and so we attempt to offer a
comprehensive program their expertise is
complemented by dedicated individuals
such as health education specialists
registered dietitians exercise
specialists who can who can go a bit
deeper than the time usually allotted to
busy clinicians so that we can really
emphasize and help patients make these
healthy lifestyle choices some of the
challenges of course are the
reimbursement is still lagging for this
kind of advice delivered in a clinical
context and also many of our patients
are used to coming back for an annual
exam or an annual mammogram for example
and so trying to stimulate their
understanding and their commitment to
making healthy lifestyle changes is also
a challenge motivational interviewing
has become a very important part of what
we do another important part of what we
do is captured here and it's a tool that
we've developed and now put in place by
several among several of our
practitioners to take again a what would
otherwise be a focal encounter and
make sure it's comprehensive so we don't
develop something termed the MD Anderson
health index that's shown on the
right-hand side of the screen it covers
very fundamental simplistic approaches
to to a seing a patient status with
regard to eleven risk behaviors and
again this is extremely simplistic it's
meant to be self-administered typically
in the waiting room before a clinical
encounter and then shared with the
practitioner at the time of the visit
and fundamentally we sum the scores very
quickly and it gives us a general guide
as to whether an individual is already
following all of the recommendations for
a healthy lifestyle or whether there's
work to do so it's a way to highlight
the importance of these issues broadly
across our entire patient population
this was developed in-house it's been
put in place over the last year or so by
a couple of our providers we tweaked it
several times to try to make sure it's
useful we have personally found it
useful it's now undergoing dedicated
study and we are also using it outside
the institution some discussions with
local provider health clinics
MinuteClinic sort of context to again
try to make sure that every encounter is
reinforcing the importance of healthy
lifestyles and now we'll get into a
little bit about what we recommend and
why we recommend these actions in our
cancer prevention center so beginning
with physical activity and this is I've
largely in this presentation
concentrated on summaries of the
existing evidence in order to make sure
that I don't highlight one study over
another so these are largely literature
compilations and this is showing the
literature as it exists from a recent
compilation around physical activity and
cancer risk that is that a risk of
developing cancer or cancer incidence
and you'll see here across some 15 or so
cancer sites there's now strong evidence
we believe to be actionable for six or
seven cancers associated with physical
inactivity you'll see the risk reduction
that's anticipated excuse me is on the
order of 20% reduction in risk with
those who are most active compared to
those who are most sedentary in these
largely observational data sets but it's
now consistent across studies and felt
to be actionable and compelling and
you'll notice that many of them also
have a dose response that is the more
physical activity that one does the
lower the risk of subsequent cancer
development this contrasts with for
several cancer types where we don't yet
have compelling data shown at the bottom
of the slide but nevertheless six or
seven cancers where we believe this is a
very important risk factor on the right
hand side of this slide I'll show you
the complementary data not for the risk
of developing cancer but for mortality
among cancer survivors and again at
least for breast colorectal and prostate
cancer there's now at least moderate
evidence of a substantial reduction in
risk among those who are most active
versus least active both related to
cancer specific mortality about a forty
percent reduced risk when more
physically active as well as for all
cause mortality again bringing in
cardiovascular benefits so we think this
is very important to highlight for our
both our at-risk population as well as
survivors physical activity is related
of course to body fatness and now we
know that obesity is linked to increased
cancer risks at some 13 different sites
that are captured in this slide you'll
note there's sufficient evidence between
underlying that association for these 13
cancers the risk associated with obesity
can be very mild something like
postmenopausal breast cancer or thyroid
cancer ovarian cancer 10% elevated risk
among those obese versus not
however in some cancers this can be
quite substantial here noting a almost
fivefold
increased risk for esophageal
adenocarcinoma and a Sevenfold increased
risk for uterine cancer so again a very
important issue for our patients and
therefore stimulate us to take action
and on the right-hand side of the slide
again those cancers for which there's
limited or insufficient evidence to
suggest an association between obesity
and cancer I'll note that we don't yet
fully understand the reasons for this
association but nevertheless it's been
consistent and therefore felt to be
actionable on this slide I've tried to
summarize quickly what we recommend
patients do about this so on the
left-hand side of the slide our physical
activity guidelines that I'll note these
are drawn from other expert bodies
largely we rely upon of both the sports
medicine society as well as the AIC are
and their recommendations in what to
suggest to our patients in there they
tend to be quite simplistic in nature of
course most of this doesn't come out of
randomized controlled trials but large
observational studies so randomized
trials are ongoing in many cases but
right now our general recommendations
are to move more and sit less throughout
the day to try to target at least a half
an hour of moderate intensity or more of
vigorous intensity physical activity and
we describe that as moderate intensity
meaning that you can still carry out a
conversation but it may be uncomfortable
vigorous intensity unable to really
carry out a conversation when working at
that level also we note the additional
health benefits that are to being better
be to be gained particularly
cardiovascular benefits and we also
recommend muscle strengthening exercises
a couple of days a week on the dietary
side again this is more or less what
what your mom taught you
but generally we strive for the the
suggestions that are made here
concentrating on whole grains fruits and
vegetables being at least two thirds of
the plate avoiding or limiting fast
foods foods that are high in energy but
low in nutritional value limiting the
consumption of red and processed meats
because of their strong association with
colorectal cancer in particular limiting
consumption of sugar-sweetened drinks of
course limiting alcohol consumption and
not relying on supplements for cancer
prevention that's very important many of
our patients think that the vitamin
supplement will protect them against
cancer and as you probably know most of
those studies and R in many cases
randomized trials have not shown to
predict a benefit and in some cases have
even shown an increase in risk at least
in subsets of the population so once
again we've taken all of this advice and
distilled it down to clinical algorithms
that we have in place here on our campus
again readily available on the web for
anyone interested I will say that these
in particular physical activity and
nutrition were hard to come by we didn't
see many examples in the published
literature and our experts spend quite a
lot of time in compiling them in every
one of them we rely upon a systematic
upfront evaluation of the need for
referral second a defined trigger for
intervention suggesting action third all
of them because we're dealing a domain
of behavior change they all rely upon
motivational interviewing and monitoring
and then finally there's an assessment
component in each of them because it's
important to not only advocate but also
assess and follow-up and continue to
encourage patients as they adopt these
healthy lifestyles next I want to share
just a couple of slides around what how
we handle tobacco so again this is the
most prominent cause of cancer and
cancer death in the American population
and certainly in Texas we in our largely
cancer patient population as well as in
the prevention center find it still the
irrelevant even though many feel that oh
well that's an old issue and it's taken
care of we find that's not the case in
our patient population some as many as a
third of our survivors smoke depending
of course on the type of cancer they may
have suffered in higher rates of smoking
our self reported by cancer patients at
diagnosis we believe it is a teachable
moment and we rely on evidence such as
compiled in the 2014 surgeon general's
report on 50 years of progress against
tobacco in terms of what we suggest to
our patients first of all there's
sufficient evidence to demonstrate
causality between smoking and a range of
adverse health outcomes surely increased
all cause mortality cancer specific
mortality as well as the risk of second
primaries in a cancer patient but
there's also suggestive evidence of poor
outcomes associated with treatment and
all of that our patients find to be
quite motivating so what do we recommend
well we like other organizations have
now put together defined guidelines for
action on the part of um busy
oncologists as well as others on the
care team both ASCO and ACR suggest that
every patient should be queried about
their smoking status and then with the
intervention to follow
if indeed there's a positive response
and what we find from the best surveys
are that 90% of oncologists routinely
routinely ask 80% advise patients to
quit but rarely thirty forty percent in
these data are they able to offer quit
assistance and so that's really the gap
and where we've tried to develop a
program to refer patients in order to
receive these kinds of interventions
unfortunately in 2019 there's a lot that
we know that we can impart to try to
advance patient success in quitting at
MD Anderson we have a very well
established tobacco treatment program
that's been in place for the last 12
years or so we use state tobacco
to support this activity specifically
it's offered to all active smokers as
well as recent quitters quitting within
the last 12 months we offer this to
patients and their family members as
well as to our own employees and their
dependents it's really important around
tobacco to treat not only the patient
but also the context in which they smoke
and that's why we we extend these
services to patients family members as
well our treatment involves an initial
clinical assessment by a clinical
psychologist most often or a addiction
psychiatrist using a standardized
questionnaire and it is all documented
in the medical record next we move on to
treatment and we rely upon a combined
strategy of both behavioral intervention
based on cognitive strategies typically
six to eight clinical counseling
sessions and with follow-up at three six
and twelve months we also provide paid
pharmacologic support using any of the
fda-approved interventions and we make
sure to schedule follow-up phone calls
or appointments in order to check on
patients across their quit journey our
program is quite successful achieving
quit rates of about 35 to 45 percent
abstinence at nine months I will also
highlight that another thing that we do
that really helps this this program
across our entire campus we now use our
EHR and the questions simple questions
about whether you smoke or not to
automate the referral process into the
tobacco treatment program we found these
data on the right-hand side of the slide
are showing this success we had about 10
referrals per day using a with provider
based referral and when we flip the
switch on the EHR automated referral
went up three to fourfold so that can be
a very important strategy in getting
this service to patients who need it and
we now also offer a
edited certified tobacco treatment
specialist training that's highlighted
here there are about 19 or 20 such
programs across the country we offer
this as well as a five-day course where
an individual not necessarily a
physician but any level provider can
come and be certified in tobacco
cessation treatment and just as with all
of our interventions this has been now
captured in a treatment algorithm and
this is page one of seven again readily
available to you if you're interested
the next area we cover in the prevention
domain is skin cancer prevention so it's
very important to educate patients about
the association between UV exposure
ultraviolet exposure and subsequent risk
of cancer and this is capturing some of
the data points that we try to highlight
for patients related to melanoma basal
cell as well as squamous cell cancer and
I'll just run through some of the
details here it's intermittent sun
exposure that is seemed to be
particularly problematic for melanoma
sunburns in childhood are particularly
concerning those who use into our indoor
tanning facilities are at increased risk
compared to those who did not
particularly early in life again and
this is showing those who endure at and
at least one time per year I'm sorry I
lost my slides
[Music]
here we go so again those who have
indoor tent a 60 percent increased risk
compared to others for basal cell
carcinoma frequent indoor tanning again
a prominent risk factor as well as early
tanning and finally for squamous cell
cancer again indoor tanning really
elevating risks so avoidance of tanning
beds is one of the major messages that
we give to patients I will highlight
that we don't suggest skin cancer
screening to general populations however
we do advocate behavioral counseling for
particularly for parents of young
children adolescents where because that
early sun exposure or tanning bed
exposure is so problematic then what we
recommend to our patients is captured on
the right hand side of this slide again
fairly common sense and straightforward
but nevertheless important for a
practitioner to highlight for their
patient population
okay so we've just recommended healthy
lifestyles as being a very important
part of clinical care why do we do that
well I've shared some of the evidence
let me show it to you now compiled
around healthy lifestyle versus not this
is a prospective data from cohort
studies as well as systematic reviews to
large studies one from the NCI the other
from the ACS you'll note that there are
some hundred thousand four or five
hundred thousand individuals in these
studies with follow-up time extending
out to 14 years and recall cancerous age
dependent and so we anticipate these
data will strengthen over time but
already there is a noted 10 to 20%
perhaps even as high as forty five
percent reduction in all cancer
incidents among adopters versus those
who practice don't practice healthy
lifestyles second there's a reduction in
all cause all cancer mortality about a
25% reduction third there's a reduction
of course in cardiovascular disease
mortality and reductions in all cause
mortality as well twenty
five - as high as 40% so for all of
those reasons trying to bolster the
uptake in practice of healthy lifestyles
is terribly important I now want to move
beyond healthy lifestyle to what we can
do medically and surgically to reduce
cancer risks and of course there's a lot
captured on the slider some of the
things though the interventions that we
know work largely through randomized
controlled trials so first of all
vaccines there are many examples there
where we now have vaccines that can
reduce cancer risk next there we have
therapeutic agents fda approved to be
safe and effective for reducing cancer
risk or treating precancerous lesions
and there are some 14 that are marketed
now this captures some of the data
around things like raloxifene or
tamoxifen to reduce breast cancer risk
critically in high-risk women or flora
uracil a whole variety of agents that
are applied topically to treat actinic
keratoses or pre cancers of the skin and
then finally even surgical interventions
have been shown to be cancer preventive
and I'll say a couple more words about
those so beginning with the perhaps best
example of cancer prevention in a
secondary context in practice is is I'm
sorry in a primary prevention context is
HPV vaccination this is showing the
results of some 26 trials that have been
conducted since these vaccines came out
about 12 years ago now and you'll see
very substantive reductions in in terms
of relative risk here for both HPV 16
and 18 which were of course the targets
of the initial vaccines almost 90 well
99 percent reduction in risk among those
vaccinated versus treated with placebo
and even for CIN 3 lesions beyond the
HPV 16 18 driven a very substantial
reduction or risk so getting patients
vaccinated for known causative agents
related to cancer terribly important
action
and of course HPV vaccination needs to
be complemented by cervical cancer
screening that's what this is calling
out specifically another very important
action to reduce risk of cervical cancer
I'll have more to say about that in a
moment
breast cancer prevention another area
where randomized trials this one's
having the NSA bpp one trial that showed
substantive 50% reductions in risk for
both invasive breast cancer as well as
non invasive breast cancer among those
randomized to tamoxifen versus placebo
with about a 5-year follow-up interval
and so now ASCO has come out
specifically and just earlier this month
come out with recommendations around
endocrine therapies for breast cancer
risk reduction and this is highlighting
that both aromatase inhibitors as well
as terms prescribed daily for five years
significantly reduced the risk for
high-risk women and this is showing the
various risk strata who might be
eligible captured there in the blue in
the small box and once again we have MD
Anderson treatment algorithms that are
related to breast cancer risk reduction
if you're interested I also wanted to
highlight the importance for those who
are substantively obese and bunneh
been unable to lose weight the bariatric
surgery has now been associated with
substantive reductions in cancer risk
this is highlighting again for a summary
of some 32 studies looking at all cause
mortality cardiovascular disease as well
as cancer both in non randomized
controlled trials as well as cohort
studies a consistent story of about a 30
percent reduction in cancer risk among
those undergoing bariatric surgery
versus not in about a 38 percent
reduction in all cause mortality so even
something as dramatic as bariatric
surgery we know it's done with one
intent in mind it can reduce cancer risk
as well as all caused mortality when
properly applied next I wanted to
highlight data a recent data for
less dramatic approaches to weight
management this is showing data from the
Women's Health Initiative involving some
36 thousand women with 11 years of
follow-up and what this is showing is a
substantive reduction in cancer risk in
this case endometrial cancer risk among
among women who lost weight versus those
who did not so an associative study
observational in nature not a randomized
controlled trial but suggesting that
significant weight loss either by in
terms of this is showing change in
pounds in the top panel there at least
10 pounds or greater about a 50%
reduction in endometrial cancer risk and
even when looked at in a percentage of
overall body weight a 5 percent loss of
weight again about a 50% reduction in
subsequent endometrial cancer risk
so again healthy lifestyles matter next
I'll move on to screening and this is
the single slide that captures
everything we recommend and screening
both for women as well as men we largely
followed the US Preventive Services Task
Force or the ACS guidelines but some of
our details differ slightly nevertheless
all of those bodies recommend
evidence-based screening and I'll now
quickly run through the screening test
that we recommend in our cancer
prevention center first - first of all
cervical cancer screening very important
and estimated mortality reduction that's
very high eighty to ninety percent so
along with HPV vaccination cervical
cancer screening strongly evidence based
highly recommended particularly women
between the ages of 21 to 65 by any
number of methods next breast cancer
screening again a b-level recommendation
for women 50 to 74 years old that's
because the mortality reduction is
estimated at at least 15 percent for
younger ages more of an individual
decision made together between provider
and patient prostate cancer
screening this has been all over the map
over the last decade or so but now
recommended to have a discussion for men
between ages of 55 to 69 considering
both the potential benefits in terms of
mortality reduction but also the
significant harms that can be associated
with subsequent intervention for
prostate cancer screen positives but I
estimated mortality reduction in some of
the studies at least on the order of 20%
colorectal cancer screening uniformly
recommended I think by all such
authoritative bodies this highlights in
particularly the American Cancer Society
that now recommends that adults be
screened as early as 45 years of age and
a level recommendation strongly
associated with reductions in mortality
anywhere between 15 to 50 percent
hepatitis B a very important to be
screened for of course there's do NATO
vaccinations that's probably the most
important but for particularly those who
were not vaccinated as infants important
to screen for hepatitis B because of the
substantial reduction here in liver
cancer risk 43 percent estimated among
those who undergo screening and
similarly hepatitis C screening should
now be offered to all who are baby
boomers born between 1945 and 65 B level
recommendation very important because
now we have effective therapies that can
be delivered over just a few months with
very substantive risk reduction for
liver cancer lung cancer screening is
one of the newest such screening tests
that are offered and it's because of
these sorts of compelling data of the N
list as well as the Nelson trial
suggests Sebata 20% mortality reduction
screening by annual CT among those at
high risk particularly 55 to 80 years of
age with a smoking history of at least
15 pack years
I want to again highlight that all of
those screening tests that I went over
rather quickly in many cases there are a
variety of different interventions that
can be applied all of those are captured
at our algorithms and progressively
moving away from simple age based
recommendations to more personalized
than tailored suggestions related to
individual risk again why that initial
HNP is so important and here I highlight
the screening algorithms that we have
available some 10 15 different sites
about how we do it at MD Anderson in
case you're interested moving on now
downstream of screens what do we do with
screen positives were we're able to
offer three varieties of what we term
undiagnosed clinics for breast cervical
cancer as well as skin lesions this
results from our own screening efforts
or in many cases referred into our
institution from a local primary care
physician who's not a funny report and
they would like it considered by our
prevention experts so we offer same-day
quick appointments in our undiagnosed
breast clinic same-day consultation
intent and confirmatory testing we
typically try to refer a provide a
diagnosis within about two days and with
subsequent referral either to our cancer
prevention center if it's not found to
be a cancer or if it is in to one of our
treatment centers and again this is the
breast example but we have similar
clinical operations for cervical lesions
as well as skin lesions the last domain
I wanted to cover for you quickly is in
cancer survivorship I mentioned that
with fortunately the population of
survivors is growing in Texas in the
nation and around the world and we think
it's important to systematically pay
attention to at least four domains and
they're captured in this slide
first of all surveillance for occurrence
or second primaries third
I'm sorry second monitoring for late
effects of treatment
third risk reduction and early detection
either for a second primary in the
primary organ or at another site since
all cancer almost all cancer is strongly
age-related and then finally
psychosocial support to try to return a
cancer survivor back to the sort of
lifestyle that they had before the
diagnosis and this is just one example
of our breast survivorship algorithm and
you can see here the four domains that
are covered there again in a much more
detail than I can then I can provide for
you in this quick summary and we have
now 30 such survivorship algorithms and
this shows the full array of what's
available readily to the public and
available on the web should you have
interest I also wanted to point out that
aligned with the American College of
Surgeons Commission on cancer we offer a
cancer treatment summary to all of our
survivors when they're leaving their
clinical provider and this is
highlighting one such example of someone
who had a breast cancer in the past they
were treated by dr. Smith and Jones so
we provide a summary of their care and
we highlight in the passport what we
term a passport here is for another
either our own practitioners or another
practitioner outside of our institution
to pay attention to in the in the green
as well as the recommended surveillance
and prevention measures that should be
taken in the green and I'm sorry in the
purple and in the green respectively
we find that this is a very well
received by both the patients as well as
primary care physicians to try to assure
that the cancer care they received at
our institution is extended out both in
time as well as geography I want to
highlight the importance of attending to
the whole patient and taking a holistic
approach to prevention and health
promotion because just as this slide
captures for a breast cancer survivor'
you get out past ten years the greatest
risk is actually for cardiovascular
disease mortality not necessarily
recurrence and death from their breast
cancer so that holistic approach of
dealing trying to help prevention
broadly is very much on our minds
fortunately in the United States as of
2010 the Affordable Care Act really
brought greater attention and focus to
preventive service delivery and captured
here are the array of screening tests as
well as preventive services that can be
reimbursed because they are recommended
by the US Preventive Services Task Force
at an ARB level this is highlighting
that these should be offered to
individuals according to defined
schedules with no copay for anyone who
has insurance either through the
government or through a commercial
provider for example a commercial agent
for example so this is very important
because it really prioritizes and
removes one of the major barriers that
is cost around receipt of these services
for insured individuals we still have an
issue unfortunately in uninsured
populations but all of this has been
proven to be effective and I've
highlighted how we deliver these
services earlier in the presentation let
me just end by highlighting that this is
what we try to do but still achieving
prevention of cancer or other diseases
is a challenge both within a clinical as
well as the population context and
Harvey Fineberg
was a speaker here in our cancer
prevention Grand Rounds on our campus
about eight years ago and we asked him
if he would commit what he had shared
with us to writing and he subsequently
did and published it in JAMA in 2013 for
anyone interested in prevention this is
really a wonderful piece and I wanted to
bring it to your attention he highlights
the prevention is challenging because
unlike in a therapeutic context where we
can really change the fate of an
individual and
prevention there's no drama many times
we're talking about statistical lives
we'll never know if the action that we
take in the patient sitting in front of
us is really effective in decreasing
their risk our saving them from a
diagnosis of cancer that may be beyond
our interaction or of course we're
looking for something not to happen many
times for payers of preventive services
they complain that well we'll invest
today but the real result will come for
20-30 years thereafter and therefore
that investment baby lost it isn't worth
our investment in order to see that
long-term benefit they may accrue to a
different pair that's true but it's it's
terribly important to try to promote
healthy lifestyles in those within our
spheres another challenge advice changes
of course science moves on and we learn
new things so that's not a problem just
for prevention but it is a problem for
prevention because so much of what we
know about prevention is is of interest
to the general public so every other day
there's a new piece of data coming out
because of general interest in issues
like nutrition or physical activity
he highlighted that many times there's a
double standard in evaluation of
preventive and treatment services that
there can be commercial conflicts of
interest and sometimes prevention
practices may conflict with personal or
cultural beliefs and approaches think of
something like the importance of tobacco
to some Native Americans rituals that
that that can be very difficult to
overcome but the good news is he also
left us with a positive side there are
many strategies to try to overcome those
and other obstacles and some of what he
shared with us is captured here paying a
little bit of these for prevention
because many times people value what
cost them a little bit secondly trying
to make prevention cheaper than being
free so I already highlighted the
importance of the Affordable Care Act
and if we can even make it the easier
choice and something that doesn't cost
patients perhaps uptake could be more
consistent and profound across a
lifetime involving employers or other
payers very important trying to make
this a part of all of the lives of our
patients such as where they work pre
engineering system so that again the
healthy choice is easier to make and
then finally I'm using multiple channels
comprehensive strategies justice has
worked in tobacco control over the last
50 years are some of the strategies to
try to deal with the obstacles so I've
covered a lot of territory and I've
tried to concentrate specifically on
what a clinician can do in the patient
and sitting in front of them to try to
promote prevention and healthy
lifestyles I hope this has been of use
to you I've left my contact information
here on the last slide so that hopefully
you can feel comfortable reaching out to
me if there's anything we can do to try
to assist you in your adoption of the of
these kinds of practices advice and
suggestions in your own clinical
practice thanks very much for your
attention
happy to take questions online